comment ça se fait qu'un directeur qui
reçoit des plaines dans une école
ne fait rien avec ça ben en fait moi je
peux pas commenter ce colonne c'est
clair qu'une direction d'école d'oie
agir quand il y a des situations qui
compromettent la réussite puis
l'éducation des élèves quand il y a dans
une classe quelle qu'elle soit un
problème mais probablement tout le monde
le sait dans l'école puis la direction
le sait aussi donc on ne l'obligation
d'agir parfois agir c'est soutenir c'est
de former c'est d'accompagner et parfois
ça suffit mais quand ça ne suffit pas
ben là on doit enclencher des mesures
disciplinaires et quand les parents font
des plaintes et qu'ils ne sont pas
satisfaits ils peuvent s'adresser à plus
haut
peuvent dire on a vu la direction ça
c'est pas réglé et ils peuvent boire
dans le centre de services scolaire et
de protecteur de l'élève le chaque
centre de service scolaire un processus
de plainte monsieur le verre disait on
ne sait plus à qui faire la plainte
quand ça bouge pas à l'école vous dites
dans les centres de service scolaire il
y a un où on peut appeler parlait une
vraie personne absolument marche
j'espère bien que ça marche je connais
pas votre centre de service scolaire là
en particulier mais vous savez que à
partir de l'automne on a le protecteur
national de l'élève qui sera mis en
place pour tout le Québec avec un
processus uniforme des protecteurs
régionaux donc peut-être un petit espace
à avoir de ce côté-là ok mais je reviens
la direction dès que vous vous
représentez les directions d'école de
Montréal oui de montré
donc une direction parce que j'entendais
aujourd'hui à mais les directions
d'école n'ont pas le choix c'est pas eux
qui choisissent les embauches j'ai pas
eu qui font ceci qui font cela quand
même une directrice d'école ou un
directeur d'école s'il se passe des
choses inacceptables dans une classe a
le pouvoir d'agir n'est-ce pas
rassurez-moi alors le pouvoir d'agir oui
parce que la direction d'école est le
premier reprise d'entendre du centre de
service scolaire on peut pas mettre un
enseignant à la porte
dire tu t'en vas chez puis là on
appellera le centre scolaire oui on peut
le faire jusqu'à un certain point puis
évidemment les enseignants sont bien
défendus par leur syndicats qui défend
qui jouent bien leur rôle et qui
défendent leurs membres donc chaque fois
que c'est à dire que quand un enseignant
par exemple on n'est pas certain qu'il
est value bien les élèves ou Londres
ramasse des faits on monte un dossier et
là le syndicat va défendre son membre ce
qui est normal c'est son rôle donc ça
demande énormément de travail de rigueur
de suivi puis les centres de services
scolaires nous soutiennent dans ce
travail-là pour amener à chaque pas vers
une éventuelle
quand j'ai dit non mais les congés
dimensions rares parce que quand on
commence à mettre un peu de pression un
peu d'encadrement ben souvent les gens
changent d'école pas parce qu'on les
change d'école mais parce qu'il nous
quittent ils arrivent ailleurs parfois
ils peuvent se reprendre partir en neuf
mais bien souvent quand on n'a pas les
compétences on ne les a pas Madame Lego
sous l'ancien régime des commissions
scolaires avec des commissaires élus
est-ce que c'était plus facile de faire
régner une espèce d'autorité d'ordre
aussi à peu près la même chose
mais peut-être que les parents avaient
une autre porte ou cogner donc il y
avait le processus des plaintes il y
avait le Conseil des commissaires il y
avait leur direction d'école bon alors
est-ce que pour certains parents ça fait
la différence peut-être ça serait
difficile de le dire mais oui sans doute
que dans certains milieux les
commissaires étaient très près des
parents et peut-être pouvait les guider
ne serait-ce que de les guider dans les
démarches puis dans leurs droits je peux
faire de comparaison boites mais pendant
le pendant la pandémie après la pandémie
ou le gouvernement on a dit on a besoin
de patrons dans les sièges SLD pour pour
sentir ce qui se passe sentir dans les
classes et tout ça moi dans mon esprit
une directrice d'école ou un directeur
d'école oh les coûts des franges pour
régler ce genre de pas régler en absolue
mais je veux dire régler les urgences
pour ne pas que les enfants soient
devant des situations inacceptables
est-ce que vos membres ont les coûts des
franges actuellement pour être des vrais
patrons ou des patrons
en partie parce qu'on choisit pas notre
personnel on ne langage pas on est de
plus en plus de personnel non qualifiés
donc on a des défis et on a besoin de
temps pour bien encadrer le personnel
qui a des difficultés est-ce qu'on a des
coups de franges écoutez on a les coups
de France
on est une limite dans nos pouvoirs
directeurs d'école comme dans tout vous
habitez directrice d'école absolument
vous là il y a une enseignante que vous
entendez crier à tutelle qu'on des
élèves vous auriez fait quelque chose
c'est une acceptable et quelque chose
absolument je me stresse assurée que les
élèves soient bien j'aurais ajouté une
ressource dans la classe j'aurais
rencontré l'enseignante j'aurais
présenté des formations je rêve
évidemment l'histoire de service
scolaire nous aident aussi ils nous ont
rien c'est ça que je veux dire parce que
là on refait le monde puis lui puis un
autre professionnel oui très bien mais
la base quand il y a un patron une
patronne c'est beaucoup des patronne des
directrices écoles
on s'occupe de son école puis ça va bien
non absolument on doit veiller sur les
élèves quand les parents nous amènent le
matin ce qui est de plus précieux pour
eux on doit prendre soin merci beaucoup
Kathleen Legault président de
l'association
montréalaise et direction
d'établissement scolaire
merci de nous avoir parlé merci à vous
au revoir